Now we're gonna have a little lesson in critical
thinking skills.
I did not compare being a stay at home mom
to doing math.
What I said was,
if my friend is going to make a bad choice,
I'm going to let her know, hey,
I think that's a really bad choice.
So in the same way that being a stay at home mother
and choosing to give up
all participation in the real fucking world
so that this other person can excel in that world
with no fucking protections for yourself,
that's a really stupid fucking decision.
I don't support that.
Not for one second.
Same thing if my friend came to me
and had another stupid decision that she was gonna do
that could have negative effects on her life.
It's called an analogy.
Sometimes people make metaphors.
It is not a direct comparison.
It is a similar event
to show you where the similarities lie.
Is a stupid fucking decision to be a stay at home mom
and give up everything to support somebody else equally
as much as it's a stupid fucking decision
to give up your whole life for drugs.
It's called critical thinking.
Let's get on it, okay?